hbo just announced on game of thrones
official twitter account that game of
thrones prequel series house of the
dragon will begin filming with the start
of 2021
beside this announcement they also tease
two dragon concept arts of the dragons
they are going to play a major role in
this prequel and those dragons are aegon
the second sunfire
and daemons characters house of the
dragon is a game of thrones prequel show
that is confirmed by hbo's president to
air in 2022
it's based on george r martin's book
fire and blood vol 1
and on mars yet unfinished fire and
blood vol 2 book
fire and blood begins their tale with
the legendary egg and the conqueror
creator of the armed throne and goes on
to recount the generations of targaryens
who fought to hold that iconic seat
all the way up to the civil war that
nearly tore their dynasty apart
that's fire and blood vol 1. the atana
released fire and blood vol 2 will
continue from where part 1 ended
with rhaenyra targaryen's son aegon the
thirds reign
and will cover blackfyre rebellions the
war with dorne and go all the way to the
mad king
and robert's rebellion attended
targaryen dynasty
the key event of the prequel will be the
dance of the dragon
a targaryen civil war miguel sapochnick
and ryan condell will serve as
showrunners and
executive producers george r martin will
also serve as executive producer
the dance of the dragons was the most
devastating war in the history of the
seven kingdoms
the war of succession between aegon ii
and his half-sister rhaenyra over their
father viserys the first throne
both of them thought they belonged on
the iron throne when people started
declaring for one of them or the other
their fight divided the kingdoms in two
targaryens fought targaryens
brothers fought brothers dragons fought
the dragons
by the time it was over thousands were
dead the conflict would prove to be
incredibly destructive for not only
house targaryen
but large parts of westeros as well
additionally devastated the targaryen's
dragon population
ultimately leading to their extinction
within a few decades
they never truly recovered by the end of
the reign of king viserys first
targaryen 20 dragons were alive
the majority of these died during the
civil war called the dance of the
dragons
which began in 129 ac and lasted until
mid 131 ac
the dragon that played a huge role in
this targaryen civil war was characters
one of the dragons hbo shared its
concept art
characters was the dragon ridden by
prince daemon targaryen during the dance
of the dragons
a veteran of many battles he was known
as the blood worm for his red scales
carraxis was one of the older and larger
dragons during the dance of the dragons
daemon targaryen rode characters in his
frequent campaigns in the stepstones
as a result characters was not only one
of the larger dragons during the dance
but the most battle hardened and
experienced in more
indeed only vegard had been ever ridden
in major wars before
during aegon's conquest but while
formidable
vegar had not been used in combat in the
years leading up to the dance
the way that charaxes was opposing
armies were known too often simply flee
or surrender when characters approached
when rhaenyra captured king's landing in
a surprise attack
daemon wrote characters in the assault
while rhaenyra road cyrex
later in the war aegon ii's younger
brother eamonn targaryen
resorted to a one-man war riding vegar
burning out much of the riverlands damon
hunted him for a long time on characters
aided by other dragon riders and their
dragons but eventually he returned alone
to harrenhal vading as a challenge for
aemond to arrive
carraxis was formidable but vagar was
twice his size
nearly as large as balerion had been
during the war of conquest
facing him alone was the only way for
daemon to drove a car out
however zaymon had avoided ambushes by
multiple other dragons
eamonn the rhyme exchanged his final
challenges to daemon
then both took to the air on their
dragons the resulting battle above the
godzilla was one of the most
epic dragon vs dragon fights of the
entire civil war
as two of the greatest living dragons
fought in the air
their shrieks shattered every remaining
window in the castle
and could be heard for miles around
their fire breath filled the skies so
that fishermen in the lake thought that
the whole sky was aflame
in the end characters down down from the
sun on aemon's blind side
due to his missing eye carraxes slammed
into vegar and they both continued to
fight in free
fall vegard tore out charax's belly
and used her massive jaws to rip one of
his wing arms completely off
but carraxes sank his teeth into the
guard's throat
and maintained a death grip as the two
dragons grappled
damon rose from his saddle and made
stunning
meet their leap from his dragon to
aemond on vegard's back
wielding the valyrian still sword dark
sister which had once been carried by
vegard's previous rider
visenya targaryen demon thrust his blade
through aemon's empty eye socket
the force of his impact as he landed
driving the sword through the back of
aemon's head
both dragons plummeted into god's eye
below both the dragons and both the
dragon riders died
daemon's corpse was never found but
aemons was found years later with dark's
sister
still thrust through its skull the
battle was a heavy blow for both
rhaenyras and aegon the second factions
each side lost one of their greatest
champions as well as each side's
strongest dragon the other dragon
concept art hbr shared is for
sunfire sunfire known as sunfire the
golden
was the mount of aegon ii targaryen
during the dance of the dragons
according to some sources sunfire was
the most beautiful dragon ever seen upon
the earth
sunfire had gleaming gold scales and his
flames were golden as well
sunfire was a relatively young dragon he
was not considered one of the large
dragons like characters
at the same time he was very much at the
upper end of the medium dragons
very strong and formidable in combat as
the conflict between aegon and rhaenyra
intensified into a full-scale war
aegon ii grew increasingly impatient
with his grandfather
otto hightower's diplomatic manurinks
and wanted to launch an immediate attack
on rhaenyra's followers on the mainland
with lord commander kristen cole he
launched a campaign into the east of the
crownlands
this culminated in the siege of the
rook's nest when reigns targaryen
arrived riding the large older dragon
milies
to attempt to leave the siege of the
castle this was all a trap however
as the greens had kept two of their own
dragons hidden and in reserve
so they could take milies in an uneven
fight
aegon ii appeared riding the younger but
strong sunfire
and his younger brother eamonn targaryen
also attacked riding massive agar
the last of the first generation
targaryen dragons
reinis could not prevail against such
odds yet she did not flee
but flew head on to meet her attackers
miley's was still so
large and powerful that she put up a
brutal fight
when the dust settled miles was dead and
vegard was relatively unharmed
but sunfire had been nearly killed and
permanently maimed
miles managed to nearly rip one of his
wing arms completely from his body
and as for aegon ii he was left
horrifically burned
and with multiple broken bones aegon ii
was taken back to king's landing
but he was left sedated with milk of the
poppy for months
and command fell to his younger brother
eamonn sunfire survived the battle
but the world's most beautiful living
dragon was left crippled and heavily
scarred
just like its rider aegon yet even after
rhaenyra captured king's landing
her forces could not find sunfire nor
aegon
aegon ii escaped king's landing to hide
out as a disguised commoner
in a fishing village on dragonstone
island the last place that rhaenyra
would search
sunfire also subsequently flew to
dragonstone after he gained enough
strength to fly
when some fire arrived he fought and
killed a remaining riderless dragon grey
ghost
although he took yet more wounds in the
process when aegon finally rode sunfire
again
he was attacked by daemon's younger
daughter bella riding the dragon
moondancer
even younger dragon barely large enough
to carry the 13 year old girl
moondancer was quick however while
sunfire was still half crippled and
slowed by his injuries
therefore they were evenly matched and
their duel was ferocious
it culminated when sunfire tackled
moondancer in midair
and drove her into the ground below his
larger size meant that he survived a
fall while she was killed
nonetheless sunfire was mortally injured
by this fight
and would never fly again when rainer
was forced to flick his landing due to a
city-wide riot
she returned to dragonstone only to be
surprised and confronted by her
half-brother
aegon ii then had rhaenyra fed to his
dragon sunfire
while forcing her last remaining son to
watch aegon iii targaryen
the dragon roasted her alive and
devoured her in six bites
six weeks after this sunfire died
despite being one of the younger dragons
in the dance
sunfire actually shared the highest
dragon vs dragon kill count with the
massive agar herself
two individual kills and one assisted
both sunfire and vogar died as a result
of their third dragon fights
for that matter they were the only two
dragons in the dance whoever lived
throughout dragon vs dragon fight and
lived
most dragons in the war were actually
killed by human armies
or died in mutual kills in their first
battle against another dragon
so many dragons had died in the war that
the targaryens could not maintain a
stable
breeding population and few survivors
became inbred and sickly
lots of dragons a lot of epic dragon
battles
all of that and more this game of
thrones prequel series house of the
dragons brings in 2022 on hbo let me
know your thoughts about everything
the prequel its characters the mighty
dragons and their epic battles in the
comment section down below
thank you so much for watching and i
hope to see you in the next one
peace
you